foreign
the big problem here not just in terms
of any individual's healing but but
sociologically is that we don't know you
said who we are let alone what a self is
we do we don't know what we're talking
about necessarily and um it's here that
um it seems that neuroscience and the
philosophy of Mind seem to promise that
we'll eventually get there that we're on
our way to some either a neuroscientific
vision of the self that um and
themselves that can hold that we can all
agree on or that philosophy of Mind
might do it um I'd like to ask our
speakers starting with Betty Sue
um do you uh do you hold out hope that
there may be some kind of reconciliation
of all these different metaphors of Self
in neuroscience and philosophy of mind
and either of them
um and would this make any difference to
the way that we live our lives
I think the question is going to get
more complicated frankly I think the
more science we do the more we're going
to find really deep issues I recently
saw a demonstration of gpt3 that uh AI
that can write and I have a dear friend
who is writing a paper using Greek myth
and psychology he's a psychology
professor and we sat on the zoom with
the gpt3 and he fed in the first part of
his very distinctive I would recognize
it as his voice paper and the gpt3 the
AI finished it in his voice I checked it
out with the classics Professor friend
of mine he got all the references right
from having been fed the internet now
this is a very this was very hard to
read the second part of the paper it was
very hard for me because
somehow the idea of a self and the idea
of a recognizable Identity or I don't
know what you would call it are meshed
uh maybe they shouldn't be but the whole
issue of AI and these um folks who don't
know whether they're talking to a real
human being or an AI and the AI
understands understands them better
these complicate the questions of what
is a self it seems to me so I don't see
an answer to these questions very soon I
think it's like physics the more you
know the more you know you don't know no
this is great who would jump who would
like to jump in here I mean does does
the um
I I think Bettis who brings up something
very interesting when it comes to AI uh
let me just first uh say that you know
in terms of
understanding what kind of begets the
self the the new neurobiological
processes I think we'll get there as as
uh you know as Humanity we'll understand
a lot about it whether that will have an
impact on an individual's behavior I'm
here with Ben say to a large extent that
this is not going to be easy to affect
change on the individual level
um and then because I I think the the
process of the self as it manifests in
each of us is kind of a runaway process
it's not it's not really tied in by the
kind of negative feedback processes in
engineering control systems like so I am
much more pessimistic about
Humanity's progression in terms of
whether we'll ever be able to make use
of this knowledge for our benefit I am
optimistic about the fact that we'll
gain the knowledge whether that will be
useful or not is a different issue uh
and and the the AI question is really
intriguing because I think uh this is
something that I've been looking into
for the last few years and
I think a lot of these questions that we
have about the self as a process will
become more and more clear as we build
AI systems that start manifesting the
same aspects and we'll we'll see very
clearly that all these things that we
take uh to be very human and very you
know emblematic of us as biological
organisms will fall by the wayside
eventually maybe not in 50 years but in
100 years or 200 years certainly and so
can I ask if you agree with this that AI
systems will help us understand better
what's going on with selfhood but it may
not be useful knowledge
I think that the general uh Congo Merit
science of cognitive science will
definitely help us understand a lot of
things and you know the dream of
cognitive science in the 80s was that
it's going to be this kind of unified
science where psychologists
neuroscientists philosophers AI people
they all work together and that you know
started promising it's not been uh as uh
maybe maybe it's falling apart a little
bit but I I believe that that's the way
we should think about the mind we should
not you know I'm a philosopher but I
think that I would be a bad philosopher
if I were not
paying attention to what neuroscientists
say about the the brain and what
psychologists say and the the dream is
to bring all these uh Snippets of
knowledge together and try to use as
many possible routes to knowledge um and
then combine them to to understand how
how the mind works that I think you're
about to head to it because I was going
to say does this not stand at some sort
of some odds
um with your hope that the importance
that you put upon changing right no so
aggregate you know I'm a big believer in
uh in the scientific inquiry about the
human mind and human brain and if we
find out more and more about how it's
just you know especially Neuroscience
giant leaps and understanding especially
uh sensory and motor processes so um I'm
a big believer that that yeah we are
getting closer to understanding how the
mind works are we getting close to how
understanding self and knowledge I'm not
so sure so uh there's many ways in which
we can relate to ourselves uh there's
this kind of knowledge relation that
I've been trying to argue that it's just
it's that's really not something we
should be really going for uh it's the
kind of constructing airtight stories
about ourselves right so that as as um
as Betty Sue would say
um and again I'm not sure that that here
uh some kind of unified coin to science
is going to uh to help us a lot but
there's other ways that you can relate
to ourselves there's a very obvious
perceptual way of relating to ourselves
uh and the sense of self and there's a
lot of uh very neat experiments that
very clearly uh help us understand how
uh
how we relate to ourselves in a tactile
or in a kind of perceptual way
um and there's also an emotional
relation to ourselves that I think uh we
could be uh we could have been talking
about and which I think is a really
important one and again we are beginning
to understand more and more about this
and then I what I love about the way the
discussion was heading to although we
didn't really go down further that way
is this self-making aspect about how uh
the decision how how much of what we're
doing is not somehow
recovering some kind of or uncovering
some kind of self that exists there but
making ourselves into some into some
person uh who who uh who didn't who
hasn't who who doesn't pre-exist itself
like this it's just that we're the
decisions that we're making the choices
we're making are creating what what the
self is going to be I think that's a
really crucial thing and again I think
there's some uh some some signs that uh
that the empirical Sciences are uh
especially in terms of the decision
making the decision science uh they are
they're helping us understanding how
that works so I'm very optimistic about
some kind of you know in interpersonal
and some kind of um understanding of how
the mind works but that doesn't mean
that we should be able
gonna call about self knowledge
asking you to weigh in on this issue of
the empirical sciences and where they're
going and how how you uh how you
estimate the progress um in in
particularly in Neuroscience a way of
looking at the world
from the outside inspecting material
entities in the cosmos
but the self is not like that the self
is a matter of experience
and it is
inevitably approached as it were from
within experience
uh I I don't say that Neuroscience can't
help us understand ourselves
one-third some 800 pages of the well
probably more like 500 pages of the book
that I've just written is purely on
neuroscience
but the conclusion I would draw is not
that Neuroscience will tell us whether
we have a cell phone or not the
Neuroscience tells us something else
which is that parts of our brain can
deceive Us in certain ways about things
like what science can tell us and about
things like what the self is
and the the stories that Neuroscience
could tell us would inevitably be of the
kind invented by the left hemisphere of
the brain which is interested in the
mechanisms the procedures
as viewed externally but that is not
what the life of a human being is that's
not what a soul is and that's not what a
a self is and I just like to say it's a
very important point that just because
one grows something doesn't mean one
made it up mm-hmm
there are things that one can grow and
the things that one can stunt but it
doesn't mean we just made them all up
out of nowhere
a very important point is the idea that
um
values for example might be what are
they they're just things that we happen
to like and we don't like so we call
these good and bad we call those
beautiful and ugly and so on
this substance in any way explain the
existence of it explains the decisions
in particular cases that we make but it
doesn't explain the existence
of such a thing as goodness or beauty in
the cosmos and I with Derek parfitt
believe who after all was a very
hard-nosed anglo-american analytic
philosopher that values are ontological
Primitives they're not accountable for
in other terms they are if you like
intrinsic in the cosmos
and that what we do with them how we
respond to them is what matters and
that's a just a very clear example of a
case where people say we could make it
all up or we have made it all up to
cheer us up but I don't believe these
things are like that I believe that we
respond to something that the universe
is a matter of relationship not just
entities in isolation that we respond to
things and by our response we may help
them come more into being or not come
into being we are in a creative Universe
physicists say this all the time there's
nothing at all unusual in physics here
biology needs to catch up on that and
that's where Neuroscience is not
philosophically or sophisticated as
physics and could easily
um come to the conclusion that it can
tell us something about whether we have
a self or not I say it to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas